the huge thanksgiving travel rush
involving tens of millions of americans
triple a predicts more than 53.4 million
people will be on the move for the
holiday up 13 percent from 2020. air
travel is up more than 80 percent from
this time last year it is almost
completely recovered from the pandemic
lows and talking of the pandemic the tsa
says is that it does not expect to see
any problems from the vaccine mandate
for federal workers the agency says
about 93 of its staff have complied with
the requirement we are joined now by the
travel expert brian kelly the ceo and
founder of the points guy who has some
tips on how to navigate the holiday rush
good morning brian how you doing i'm
doing good thanks for having me of
course now there will be millions of
americans expected to travel i mean you
have some tips for them absolutely well
i mean i think the first thing is don't
panic i think all the headlines leading
into this week were meltdowns staff
shortages certainly there will be some
hiccups but the weather seems to be
holding up and by and large travel
should be pretty smooth this week but
prepare for lines you know get to the
airport early and also get tsa pre-check
it's 85 for five years and i struggle to
find a better way to spend 17 a year
than to save hours in line each and
every time you go to the house i also
love clear
clear also yeah if you want to splurge a
little bit more you know so if you have
tsa pre-check like i do clear actually
gets you to the front of that pre-check
lane so sometimes you feel the daggers
of people like the combination of the
two right yeah the cool kids line why
are you cutting that hey but do you have
a system though about navigating lines
cause listen whenever i see people with
baby carriages and strollers and kids in
diaper bags i go i don't want to get in
that line okay i know i don't like to
profile people but i don't disagree with
that approach i know but then you switch
to the other line and it moves it moves
faster and then you're backwards you
know i think by the time you're at the
left once again i think this is a mental
thing like whether you're going to save
another two minutes the point is get to
the airport early early enough where it
doesn't matter you know those extra two
minutes but the pre-check line in
general you have to take your shoes off
you don't take your laptop out so i
can't stress enough how that is just so
you have tips traveling with children
though absolutely so if you're traveling
with children and actually anyone
traveling whether it's now or in six
months check your airline reservations
the airlines have made so many changes
to the schedules times and a lot of
times they change the plane type so if
you're a family of four sitting together
and they change the plane you might be
scattered all over the flight so check
it today because it's a lot easier to
fix it before you're at the airport you
know in that long line so you're getting
there early which means you might work
up a little bit of a hunger before
actually board but everything at the
airport cost ten thousand dollars
and the lines are crazy eat before you
go to the airport okay bring snacks
absolutely what can you get through
security so you know the tsa you can
actually bring a fully baked turkey
through the tsa pre-check
called the nate rule
can you bring macaroni and cheese
somebody sent me some macaroni and
cheese that i'm taking with me on the
paper if it's not too watery in general
if you can you know spray it spill it or
spread it you need to check it so if
it's like a real date again spray it
spray it spread it spill it uh-huh you
could you should check it but if it's
like a hard casserole or a turkey or a
ham you can totally bring those through
even beverages if they're fully frozen
you can bring it through a tsa yeah
someone's gonna film you with that
macaroni security line it came it's in
the freezer now but i'm taking it thank
you benny medina it's the best macaroni
and cheese i've ever had what about when
you're tracking your planes to figure
out you know because you call to seize
my plane on time the weather's sunny
here you're thinking i'm all good here
so the one-on-one thing to do is just
you know set your flight status with
your airline track your flight get push
alerts but this is what the experts do
we check where your plane is coming from
right because it can be nice and sunny
here in new york but if it's snowing in
chicago so you want to check where your
flight's coming from you also does that
though brian nerds like me and nerds
like me if you're a plane nerd there's
actually an app called flight radar 24
where you can point your uh
your phone in the sky and it'll tell you
what that flight is where it's going
really yeah but flight aware is a great
flight tracking tool it'll help you
track where your plane's coming from and
honestly that little bit of information
will give you the head up heads up
because if you know your flight's
delayed where it's coming from chances
are it's going to be delayed for you and
that's when you can change your flight
get on an earlier one and get home to
the family without being now brian
recently i sat down with the hall of
fame celtic bill russell the reason i
bring that up is because i met him in
boston i flew out there he drove with
his wife from the state of washington
all the way to boston wow which shows me
that during the holiday season people
will find a reason to hit the road and
not get on the plane wow so what do you
recommend for those that are going to
hop in the car instead of going to the
airport well if you're renting cars book
as far in advance as possible book
directly with the car rental agency
because they are selling out and a lot
of people are showing up and there's
just no cars people are you know now
working from home not returning them
also leave early and also don't think
you know driving is that cheap we've all
seen gas prices through the roof so
what about unruly passengers i haven't
been on a flight luckily knock on wood
where you see somebody going off on the
flight attendant what should we do in
that situation i think it would be very
hard to just sit and witness that you
know and of course tape it so it goes
viral but no we need to support our
front you know front of the line travel
uh personnel they are under so much
stress just getting us you know travel
has whipped back so quickly they're not
staffed appropriately
so we have to support you know flight
crew don't intervene necessarily but if
things are getting out of control
absolutely it's you know be an upstander
when you see someone behaving terribly
we have to support because flight
attendants it's not their job to be
security guards you're talking about
planes but when you brought up on really
passengers i thought you met family
members in your rental car
[Laughter]
what do you do then you're you're a big
guy if i sit next to you i'll be like oh
yeah there's an air marshal right here
we're good to go go get em brian thank
you so much for joining us